[Musique]
cent trente mille cas de covin chaque
jour on voit refleurir sur nos trottoirs
les tentes blanches devant les
pharmacies un salarié sur dix est absent
de son entreprise depuis la reprise des
cas positifs de covin la disparition des
gestes-barrières l'absence maintenant du
port du masque obligatoire serait à
l'origine de ce rebond nous avons libéré
repine beau travail les occupants sont
repoussés mais il est encore trop tôt
pour parler de sécurité les combats se
poursuivent et les troupes russes
tiennent le nord de la région de kiev et
dans les échanges entre russes et
ukrainiens on a cru sentir un léger
changement de ton
[Musique]
après trois heures de discussions c'est
chose faite les ukrainiens annonce une
avancée notable
les russes ont bien reçu notre document
où nous indiquons clairement les moyens
de finir la guerre ils vont l'étudier
est la réelle avancée et c'est que la
russie serait prête à accepter une
adhésion de kiev à l'union européenne si
et seulement si elle reste militairement
non alignés et abandonne l'idée de
rejoindre l'otan pour favoriser la
confiance mutuelle et obtenir à terme un
accord global
le ministre de la défense a décidé de
réduire drastiquement l'activité
militaire en direction de kiev et de
tchernigov joe biden qui qualifiait
poutine de boucher qui ne peut pas
rester au pouvoir le président américain
précise son propos j'ai juste exprimer
mon ressenti en disant que cet homme ne
devait pas rester au pouvoir de la même
façon que les mauvaises personnes ne
doivent pas continuer à faire de
mauvaises choses mais cela ne veut pas
dire que nous avons l'intention de faire
quoique ce soit pour renverser le régime
de poutine le milliardaire roman
abramovitch aurait été victime d'un
empoisonnement il y a quelques jours
après une rencontre à kiev l'oligarque
et deux membres de l'équipe de
négociation ukrainiens ont développé
d'étranges symptômes les yeux rougis et
larmoyants le visage et les mains qui
pèle ils ont tous les trois développer
ces symptômes après une réunion à kiev
courant mars depuis ces symptômes se
sont améliorées et leurs vies ne sont
pas en danger selon le site
d'investigation pauline cat les doses
ainsi que le type de toxine administrés
étaient insuffisants pour causer la mort
leur but aurait été simplement
d'effrayer les victimes j'ai
l'impression que vous dites et coûté 6,1
crier ma croissant ce qu'ils avaient une
bonne raison en tout cas je ne sais pas
qui ils avaient de bonnes raisons c'est
qu'effectivement il y a des raisons
d'être furieux sur les prix sur
l'essence le gaz il n'y a pas de recette
magique parce qu'on ne les produit pas
donc qu'est ce qu'on doit faire on doit
acheter moins bas c'est pour ça qu'ils
bas en europe et 1 ça paraît un peu
technique mais il faut que nous on a ils
réussirent à moins dépendre de la russie
à réussir à faire baisser les prix en
achetant mieux ce qu'ils ont voulu crier
c'est que le laxisme tue car ce sont des
gens qui n'auraient pas dû être là ce
sont des gens qui n'auraient pas dû être
en france et qu emmanuel macron et le
pouvoir en général à laisser rentrer
[Musique]
est ce que vous pensez sincèrement que
l'on peut reconstruire la france avec
des français déprimé à qui on va leur
dire travailler plus à qui on leur dit
chauffez vous - parce qu' il faudrait se
passer du gaz russe à qui on dit vous
pouvez plus construire de maisons manger
plus de viande serrez vous la ceinture
et mais ça va quoi ça c'est la france de
la déprime
pendant cette campagne et en particulier
avec que ce meeting je comprends
pourquoi les gens détestent les
journalistes je le comprends maintenant
je comprends que les médias cherchent à
toute force à protéger et manuellement
ou les candidats la présence et de son
énoncé